Final thought on histogram--it's certainly possible, even desirable to combine these methods.
For instance, the disadvantage of the atomic method is that a large number
of threads are trying to get simultaneous access to bins,
so most threads end up waiting around.
If we could reduce the number of threads trying to simultaneously
access an atomic, that would remove the bottleneck.
So, we might choose to use the reduction technique within a block
to combine all the individual histogram operations from each thread in that block into a single histogram,
then use a single thread within that block to add that per-block histogram into the global histogram.
For instance, if we have 256 threads in our block and 8 bins in our histogram,
we might choose to do our implementation 1 of 2 ways.
One is that each individual thread within our block atomically increments a global bin.
Another is that we can take the 256 threads that we have, each one containing a single measurement,
and then reduce them within the block, locally, to produce one 8-element histogram.
Then, use that 8-element histogram to update the global histogram.
For each of these, how many atomic adds are we going to need to do?